So many of the resources we
have in life, such as time and
money, are limited.
So we have to be efficient in
how we decide to use them.
For example,
there's only 24 hours in a day.
And if we decide to spend one of those
hours watching the latest TV drama,
we can't use that same hour to, say,
cook a delicious meal with friends.
So, this ultimately
means that we should be
careful of how we decide
to use that type.
Similarly, the human memory is
a limited resource as well.
We can only hold so
many things in our head, right?
For example, at a party,
we have a limit to the number of
new names that we can remember.
Our mobile devices have
memory of a digital kind,
and that memory is fixed and
extremely limited compared to that of a
traditional laptop or desktop computer.
Now memory on our mobile device is
used to store all types of things,
such as music, text messages,
photos and much more.
Now on top of all this,
that limited amount of memory
must also be shared across
the Android operating system for
all the other awesome apps that we use,
including our app as well.
So if one of these apps ends
up eating up a lot of memory,
that can have a significant impact
on running all the other apps.
And worse of all, that would negatively
effect the overall experience of
the entire device, which could lead to
a very frustrating user experience.
All of this discussion is meant to say,
that as developers we must keep in mind
that memory is a limited resource, and
we need to create apps that
use this memory efficiently.
Consider the contacts list app.
A user may have 1,000 names and phone
numbers stored into their contacts list.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Now, if each contact were stored as
TextViews in a linear layout, the phone
would expense a lot of memory creating,
storing, and displaying 1,000 TextViews.
Even though maybe not all 1,000 would be
shown on the screen at the same time.
If a large part of the system's memory
goes into creating and storing 1,000
contacts, then there's not much left
to run other parts of the phone.
And this may cause other apps
to stall or not even run at all.
We want to be smart about
using the memory resources so
our app plays nicely with
other programs on the device.
Now, in this simplification of a
contacts app, when the user's looking at
the list on their phone, they only see
five contacts on the screen at a time.
And anything above or below the list
currently visible on the screen
doesn't even need to exist, because that
would just take up memory resources.
So there's no need to create all 1,000
TextViews and have them take up memory,
especially since the user may never
scroll through the entire list.
So, to solve this issue, we could reuse
views, because there's only five to
seven contacts that would ever actually
appear on the screen at the time.
And so here the blue rectangle
represents the device screen.
So notice that all of the contacts that
do end up needing to be displayed can
just use one of these pre-created views.
And when a contact is no
longer visible on the screen,
then the view can be used to display
information for a different contact.
So this strategy is
called view recycling.
And we can accomplish this with
a combination of a ListView and Adapter.
So we'll talk more about the details
of this whole view recycling process
in more detail in the next video.
So the takeaway is to remember not
to abuse your device's memory.
Remember that our apps run on devices
that have a set amount of memory
that it needs to share with
other apps and functions.
So if a device is running several
applications at a time and
runs out of memory because maybe your
app is hogging all the resources.
Well, the device will have to stop
running all the other apps in order to
free up space.
Now, armed with this knowledge,
we can all be good citizens when
creating apps for Android devices by
ensuring that they efficiently minimize
the amount of memory they're using.